that's amazing that's crazy that's some
BFF [ __ ] I want you to be my president
yeah you are my president there's so
much better friend okay
hey what's up Mike we're here at
BuzzFeed I'll just take the BFF test I'm
excited you know would be next and for
best friends [ __ ]
okay well they're gonna blip that
oh I hate Percy oh that's so easy this
is I'm basing this off of what do you
like [ __ ] up at a coffee shop yeah
too short [ __ ] yeah you do sing that oh
yeah you don't sing [ __ ] alright what'd
you say yeah I do love that one to be
fair folks pretty sick there's a good
one I feel like all of your talents
you've done now there's you know you see
oh man
yes not many how good I am at hacky sack
myself yeah only I studied whatever yeah
let's go Soph with a little oh the
French bread dude it's Germany's worth
of Yuans broken toys have booths
he's just world I out in the house you
lot yeah impress them
[Music]
oh you guys both have a makes me same
idea now I'm like having some sort of
underground hip-hop knowledge right
really a backpack rap by Peck rapper you
know I said makes me seem smarter yeah I
feel pretty seems I make you guys feel
seem not you feel seem right yeah I just
think about it
mm-hmm a little bit of - that's weird
this is a really powerful now I know why
you guys are BuzzFeed seem high M high I
am currently I'm not even gonna write it
I'm just gonna say shaggy
sure shaggy yeah we're done writing yeah
wait no I I don't know plays a song what
is it like just tell us
dude we're not writing it so you might
not choose you would just want to know
yeah no scrubs
oh no scrubs yeah you feel guilty about
like you know because I feel like I am a
scrub and I feel bad about like calling
out my people right cuz you're no
pigeons guy yeah I'm gonna pick it up it
was good no it was a weird head but no
sprouting it actually no I'll answer
this one
yep this is ready
what honors is right in his correct
[Music]
thing that's pretty good making a
sailor's win champ
while car oh well your sentence game is
an all-time lonely 100 years ago I'm
working holidays dogs we're talking
about the new movie we're morning game
over man
oh talk about our whole lives hold on it
was fun that was cool we're getting
pulled in like a car you know it was
season one of workaholics yeah and we
listened to the championship basketball
game on the radio while we were shooting
it and that was great but yeah then
they'd stare at my dick while I had it
out for this movie was up for a day for
a full day like any that's a permission
to be myself as a our smiles
I just wrote feeling something dies
inside said yeah yeah wow that's really
nice
hey I give you permission putting around
everyone else I'm like yeah I monitored
her see you
[Music]
no physical from Big Trouble in Little
China yeah that is pretty good I don't
know if you'd actually send it okay wait
what new phone who did oh you asked me
over the phone okay yeah next yeah
respect I know what you'd call it yeah I
didn't like that one I did not like that
well that was shoehorn yeah that one was
that one was shoehorn the rest of being
all right now I know I felt buds it is
called buttons yeah we not start that
because it's like yeah all right yeah
well we have a bun in sight that we're
starting sorry Buffy depends how long
the break is yeah that's true I do play
2k and happens I'm coming from there or
he's asleep world wide a way there's no
in-between
yeah and that's why we call them either
eating or drinking Red Bull buzzing or
feeding
[Music]
oh you didn't dig - oh yeah ders has a
secret emoji of just a dick that that I
feel like he should start to use mmm
I blew it this one saves the day
birthday boy remember that phase that I
was going through where I'd come up and
sneak up on you guys in kiss her
shoulders
did I not like that yeah he likes that
one be like oh that was it cool cool
that yeah it's a fun pit that I know
bleep boy there's no one else
yeah no peace peeve what does it show
wine yeah yeah I got nothing disgust
paint was your room is messier than mine
is it yeah I just remember when we lived
together there's lots of dishes stacking
I don't do dishes so me I'll take it
sure you're not missing I'm not missing
Wow
you fold your fast food wrappers so that
you do so that immediately is says
you're not missing okay
well you know I'd like to play bed
rhymes so he has to has to be a divine
come on he's got that pitch perfect
swing yeah you have that slang all that
cloud yeah but that hair will get you it
yours could talk you in the club yeah oh
he'll get you in using his wits and
bravado hey uh can we get in there or
not no okay another time I got us in by
going like we're on Stephanie's list and
somehow it worked
yeah evidently there was just stuff man
though that when every bar remember in
Vegas when you tried to convince him you
were a cast member of SNL yeah
Andy bowline yeah this is before yeah
yeah yeah we were that didn't work yeah
yeah believe it or not Blake isn't I had
to push Blake down the weed path yeah
you've been lobbying way longer you got
me into it
gateway drugs though so huh yeah thanks
Adam hey guys no I had that was stupid
okay okay
no I with a hey guys there's women out
there hey what's up people human versus
yeah what's up all the people out there
yeah we're the guys were game over man
and workaholics and we're saying ie yeah
I didn't like what I did at the end with
the buyers held on too many years your
faith you're being critical of yourself
thank you it was back to your baby thank
you for being honest husband a little
kissing up move oh it's - I get why you
guys yeah it's weird it sends shivers
down your spine
yeah I don't know yeah that was a weird
phase Hospital
[Music]